[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
bastien ray chez trésorier de génération
s bonsoir bassins riches et merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce soir alexis
villepelet porte-parole de debout la
france à vos côtés bonsoir à vous aussi
lui merci à tous les deux d'être en
direct
je vois donc la société sera socialiser
progressivement nous dit s'alarmer en
tout cas emmanuel macron qui dénonce
donc le cumul des discriminations
lorsqu'on fait partie de plusieurs
minorités
vous partagez bastien ray chez le
constat du président de la république
mais non c'est pas très bien où il veut
le président de la république à propos
de 2,7 de ce compte de ce qu'on sait du
constat qui est fait aujourd'hui ce
qu'on observe en revanche c'est
effectivement 22 polémique aujourd'hui
sur sur la question des discriminations
en france
et moi je voudrais simplement rappeler
effectivement qu'on est aujourd'hui dans
une situation où l'état ne fait pas
assez dans la lutte contre les
discriminations et où il ya
effectivement des des cumuls de
discrimination qui se font et vous avez
effectivement des cumuls de
discrimination sociale est aussi
d'origine ethnique et et la promesse
républicaine du coût est souvent un vin
bout d'un certain nombre de territoires
et donc quand on est d'ailleurs le
président qu'à supprimer l isf
contourner le président qui a été le
président des violences policières
notamment la crise des gels et jaune je
crois que il est assez peu
correct de s'exprimer de cette façon sur
la question de la lutte contre les
discriminations bastien ray chez vous
vous pensez qu emmanuel macron au
contraire a eu raison de faire ce
diagnostic vous le partagez
moi je partageais hakim peuvent pas
poser la question excusez moi avoue même
si vous vous partagez vous ce constat ce
diagnostic chef oui oui je partage ce
des moustiques mais il le fait au bout
de quatre ans oui il le fait au bout de
quatre ans si vous voulez quatre ans
c'est beaucoup c'est où seulement bout
de quatre ans qu emmanuel macron
s'attaque ou sujets régaliens
vous savez il est lié à cette fois sur
le séparatisme et à ses lois sur sur
l'ordre enfin c'est cet intérêt sur
l'ordre quand on a mais quatre ont pour
s'intéresser aux sujets régaliens
c'est que ce n'est pas une priorité
monsieur mâcon je lui donne fait quitus
d'une certaine priorité sur l'économie
il a fait la loi travail laly sf comme
l'a dit mon contradicteur mais sur le
régalien je lui donne aucun je lui fais
pas quitus du tout de s'y intéresser et
ça me fait penser vous savez aux mauvais
élèves qui juste avant l'examen l'examen
étant ici les présidentielles
naturellement à la va vite et c'est de
travailler rapidement les sujets
importants qu'ils n'auraient pas vu et
on le voit bien d'ailleurs que c'est que
c'est bâclé à ceci que ses ministres et
ses les députés en mars n'ont pas l'air
très au courant de cette nouvelle ligne
je pense tout à l'heure vous en parliez
dans votre journal à au débat entre
madame genevard député maire et monsieur
moretti madame je ne leur parle de
drapeaux dans les mairies de dons dans
les mairies de rodéo et monsieur moureu
ti dupond-moretti pardon la renvoie d'un
revers de main en se moquant d'elle sur
laon parlant des danses du smur je ne
sais trop quoi il faut serait temps
si jamais il voulait s'attaquer à ce
sujet important
sérieusement qui vise à ses ministres
attention je pense aussi à la députée
madame bergé qui avait tenté de
présenter un amendement sur le voile
pour les petites filles qui avaient été
repoussés
par la majorité la propre majorité de
madame berger en marche voilà un moment
il faut être cohérent et vrai
véritablement ça me semble pour des
motifs assez électoraux que brutalement
le président note lui que s'intéresse à
ça mais petit personnel je trouve
qu'effectivement il faut s'intéresser à
ce sujet effectivement c'est à polémique
aujourd'hui qui rejoint notre thème du
débat du jour je voudrais donc vous
faire écouter annie genevard avant de
vous faire réagir va serrer chez
lorsqu'on y marier dans une mairie
française dans un bâtiment public il
faut se plier aux codes chaque fois en
tant que maire que nous avons affaire à
ce genre de situation ça suscite
beaucoup d'émoi dans la population
sahin supporte les gens à basse-terre et
cher cette fois pardonnez moi pour les
le petit mais l'enjeu des noms tout à
l'heure là on est vraiment dans
l'illustration de ce qu'on appelle la
racialisation est ce que c'est de ça que
l'on parle on mélange pour les sujets
selon vous moi j'ai pas bien compris ce
que voulait dire le président de la
république notamment parce que peut-être
parce qu'il a plusieurs lignes
politiques à l'intérieur de son
gouvernement et que effectivement en
train eric dupond moretti un gérald
darmanin parfois on ne sait pas très
bien quelle est la position du président
de la république elles sont et de même
de son parti en marche
en revanche moi je suis partiellement
choqué par les propos qui sont tenus
évidemment par par sept députés
j'étais moi-même adjoint au maire dans
un arrondissement parisien
donc j'ai eu à faire un certain nombre
de mariages et de mariage divers
populaire et cette espèce de
stigmatisation qu'on fait et ça c'est
vraiment pénible et me relève bien du
climat aujourd'hui qui quitte en a
justement un pointé du doigt une partie
de la population française et on voit sa
ronde de polémiques re surgir là du coup
et qui d'ailleurs installe le climat
politique pour pour cette présidentielle
donc si effectivement la préoccupation
du chef de l'état c'est de courir après
l'extrême droite de courir après marine
le pen et que en mettant au coeur des
débats finalement
des prises de positions qui sont celles
de l'extrême droite française dans ses
diverses expressions
je pense qu'effectivement on court de
graves dangers pour pour cette élection
présidentielle et que lui-même cours de
grave danger par rapport à la question
de sa réélection mais j'espère qu'au
contraire on aura en face la gauche et
l'écologie qui apaise et pourront
justement faire en sorte que la première
république à ne soit pas un vain mot et
qu'on cesse de discriminer et de
stigmatiser systématiquement ce que je
dis bien systématiquement les mêmes
personnes c'est-à-dire les personnes de
quartiers populaires issus de
l'immigration
alors je mettrai en tout cas le maire a
l'air de salon que annie genevard
écoutez le le problème c'est l'afrique
du nord moi j'ai marié des colombiens
des ukrainiens je n'ai jamais eu de
problème j'ai des problèmes avec des
débordements liés à certains mariages de
personnes issues du maghreb
donc en novembre 2018 on a réglementé
j'ai pris un arrêté interdisant les
emblèmes étrangers les chants les danses
à l'intérieur de l'hôtel de ville
effectivement j'ai le fait qu'ils
nomment l'afrique du nord en parlant de
ces drapeaux 1
parce que c'est ce qui a beaucoup choqué
est ce que par exemple les drapeaux
étrangers ont leur place effectivement
lors de mariages ou des ordres de la
république française
alexis villepelet est-ce qu'on est en
plein dans ce débat sur le
particularisme
alors pour moi dans un hôtel de ville
lors d'un mariage les drapeaux quel
qu'il soit c'est qu'ils soient
américains d'afrique du nord d'asie
n'ont pas leur place on dans la dans une
dans un hôtel de ville et cela pour moi
les seuls drapeaux étrangers qui peuvent
voir leur place et par exemple au monde
cérémonie du 8 mai ou de choses comme ça
sinon on est c'est une question
d'autorité de l'état dans l'état dans la
mairie dans la salle de mariage il ya le
drapeau français il ya le maire il ya le
buste de marianne et c'est tout
c'est une question d'autorité de l'état
alors attention ne mélangeons pas tout
ne commençons pas mais d'ailleurs
monsieur platret lesmont sont sales son
édile a fait pour tous les drapeaux il a
pas ce qui m'a teasé tel ou tel qu'une
telle population
il ya la question des drapeaux mais
aussi la question du respect de l'ordre
public
on voit de plus en plus enfin de plus en
plus heureusement l'écrasante majorité
des mariages se passe bien il faut le
dire on va raconter d'un protocole non
plus mais on voit aussi de plus en plus
des rodéos lors de mariages on a vu à
lens une autoroute boucher parce que il
y avait un mariage avec une lamborghini
ou des gens faisait n'importe quoi enfin
il faut respecter l'autorité de l'état
dans ce pays et tout ce qui pourra être
fait pour aller dans le sens du respect
de l'autorité de l'état et est une bonne
chose et les maires
si vous voulez les maires ont autorité
pour interrompre les mariages mais les
mariages
enfin pas nul mais interrompre les
mariages pardon mais la difficulté pour
eux c'est qu'ils sont un peu seul
parfois ils sentent un peu seuls ils
n'osent pas forcément toujours à
intervenir donc il faut les mettre en
condition pour intervenir je ne sais pas
s'il faut légiférer mais en tout cas il
faut qu'ils sachent que l'appareil de
l'état n'est derrière eux quand ils ont
des sujets de ce genre de genre de
personnes qui vont faire des rodéos
après un mariage ou qui vous qui veulent
se pointer dans une mairie avec des
drapeaux étrangers
dernière réaction a commenté pour vous
bastien richesse celle de karl olive ans
le maire génération terrain depoisier
côté emmanuel macron est convaincu de
l'universalisme ce que je partage
il nous faut même aller plus loin dans
notre lutte
entre la racialisation à commencer par
le retour d'une vraie mixité sociale
dans nos quartiers l'universalisme comme
moyen de lutter contre le racialisme
parce que c'est pas justement ça le
problème va sécher on veut gommer les
identités en profits dont john c'est
quoi on appelait ça la mondialisation
heureuse il y a quelques années
le problème c'est que on se gargarise de
mots sont d'une part les maîtriser les
comprendre et d'autre part son tenir
compte des réalités - encore une fois
l'exemple des mariages montre bien qu à
part quelques débordements tout ça tient
du fantasme
voilà et mon contradicteur me disais
tout à l'heure à l'immense majorité se
passe bien donc encore une fois faire du
fantasme comme on dirait un cadre
ensuite pour le débat politique et c'est
absolument à proscrire et ensuite moi je
parlais tout à l'heure de promesse
républicaine
moi je suis républicain effectivement
mais je crois qu'au large puisqu'elle
doit être partout voilà et quand vous
avez des territoires où on ferme les
bureaux de poste où les écoles sont de
plus en plus dégradées les collèges
également que vous n'avez même pas
distributeurs seront de quartier moi
j'ai travaillé dans des villes où il y
avait même pas de distributeur de
billets donc voilà et donc quand vous ne
faites pas respecter un minimum
justement cette promesse d'égalité
républicaine et cette question
finalement d'égalité des droits
effectivement l'universalisme c'est un
vain mot et donc moi je voudrais que
on essaie en tout cas de prendre un peu
de distance et un peu de sérieux face à
ces questions qui sont vraiment des
questions des questions graves et qu'on
arrête ce que parce que là vous venez de
nos cités alors peut-être moins le
dernier mais venant d'un maire de droite
qui lutte lui même contre l'implantation
de logements sociaux c'est quand même
assez cocasse mais en tout cas
j'aimerais bien qu'on arrête le concours
lépine justement des idées racistes
visant les stigmatisant la population
maghrébine vivant en france se serait ce
serait vraiment une bonne chose pour 7
pour le début de cette élection
présidentielle est en tout cas je le
disais tout à l'heure
génération au sein du pôle écologique on
va effectivement faire en sorte de
ramener le débat sur les vraies
questions de fond c'est à dire les
questions sociales et légales l'urgence
climatique parce que je pense que c'est
le plus important pour les mois qui
viennent et les années qui viennent
évidemment
merci en tout cas à tous les deux
bastien ray chez alexis villepelet
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france